a simple Quantum sketch with application
SC hi yeah so thank you Andrew um yeah
so I want to tell you about a simple uh
Quantum sketching primitive and how you
can use it to get uh provable Quantum
space Advantage for a couple of natural
streaming
problems and so I want to start by
thinking about a very simple problem
that you already know how to
solve um
and this problem is you have a set s
living in some Universe U and you want a
succinct sketch of s that solves uh the
following two
problems uh so I want to be able to come
along with another set P also living in
U and estimate the size of the
intersection between S and P uh to say
error may be a constant uh times the
size of s
and if uh these two sets have a decent
amount of overlap I also want to be able
to sample a random element from within
that
overlap like I said this is a very
simple problem that we already know how
to solve all you have to do is take a
constant number of samples from your set
s and make that your sketch so then you
know someone comes along with a set P
they want to estimate the intersection
size they just have to count how many of
the samples land in their set p and you
know if they want to sample something
from the intersection they can just take
one of your samples that lands in P at
random okay so we know how to solve this
problem but what if I make it a bit
harder instead of having P be a set of
Singleton elements I'm going to have P
be a set of disjoint pairs from this
universe
U and again what I want to be able to do
is like estimate how much of the set s
is covered by these pairs in p and if
it's a large enough fraction of s I also
would like to be able to return one of
these pairs P at
random um and so solving this with kind
of a trivial sampling argument is going
to be quite a bit harder because you
know your probability that your random
sample you took from s will include both
elements of some pair and P is going to
be a lot lower and in particular you
know like by the kind of standard like
birthday Paradox kind of argument the
number of samples you'd need would be
about the square root of the size of s
and you can actually show by a reduction
to the uh Boolean hidden matching
problem in oneway communication
complexity that like this is optimal up
to a log Factor any like classical
sketch that solved this problem would
need a square root of s many
bets um but
if you've seen the Boolean hid matching
problem before one thing that you'll
know about it is that this problem
actually exists to prove uh exponential
separations between Quantum and
classical uh communication
complexity and so what I'm going to tell
you about now is a sketch inspired by
this um Quantum protocol for Boolean
hidden matching um that can solve these
problems using only uh logarithmically
many
cubits and so uh the sketch is is going
to let you do this cardinality
estimation problem count the number of
pairs in P that are contained in s and
it's going to let you do the sampling
problem if like enough pairs in
contained in s you'll be able to sample
one of
them with the caveat uh that you that um
you know if one of these pairs in p has
like only a size one intersection with s
there will still be some chance of
returning it but when you do so you'll
have a 50% chance of getting a minus one
label so if you're imagine if you're
doing anything like in
expectation with um these samples then
you can make sure you can still make
sure it's
correct okay so um how can we construct
a sketch with these uh these
properties uh
and I guess I should s say is the whe
this is it's clear what what we're doing
what what the sketch can
do okay so to construct it we're going
to need a uh a couple of quantum
Primitives
um so um these are going to be the
concept of a
superposition and so the way that you
should think about this is that if you
have some like classical un vers U uh a
superposition will be a length one
vector in the vector space the complex
Vector space where each uh basis element
is one of the elements of
U and um we'll use this kind of this K
notation to denote um these individual
basis
elements and so and in the same way that
you can represent a single element of U
classically with log size of the
universe Cube uh classical bits you can
represent an arbitrary superposition
over you with log size of the universe
cubits now if we could take one of these
superpositions and like extract every
single uh coordinate of it every single
amplitude we call it in this context
then um we'd be able to break all kinds
of uh you know information theoretic
lower bounds um but instead we're
restricted to uh accessing these superp
positions uh via measurements and
there's a lot of ways of
formalizing U measurement uh but the one
that I'm going to use here is this idea
of a projective
measurement uh so you so how this works
is you construct um a family of
projectors on this uh Vector space uh C
to the U that sum to the identity and
each to each of these projectors you
attach a label which you can think of as
a measurement outcome um and then when
you do this measurement your probability
of getting a given measurement outcome
is just the squared length of the vector
after you project it down onto the
corresponding
projector because these projectors sum
to the identity it's going um these
probabilities will sum to one um and um
you know if you could do these
measurements repeatedly you would also
be able to extract all of the
coordinates of the the superp position
and break everything um but in instead
when you do this measurement is
essentially destructive like when you
measure a superp position whatever your
outcome is uh your uh your superposition
Vector gets projected down onto that
outcome projector and then renormalize
to be length
one okay so with these two Primitives uh
we're going to be able to uh build a
sketch that satisfies uh the criteria
that I mentioned earlier and um the
sketch we do will actually be very
simple um our sketching state is just
going to be a number of copies of the
uniform superp position over the set s
remember the set s is the set that we
wanted to sketch um and by that I mean
it's going to be a ve the vector that's
exclusively supported on the elements of
s
um and where the uh amplitude of each of
these um on on each of these coordinates
is going to be the same real number
which means that since it's supposed to
be a length one superposition it's going
to be one over square root of the size
of s each
time um then when we go to query this uh
this sketch we're going to perform a
measurement um built made out of
projectors that we build from the pairs
in our kind of query set P um
and so these projectors for each XY each
each of these pairs XY are going to be
the projectors onto X Plus Y and onto x
minus y um and because we required that
P was the set of disjoint pairs it's
going to be possible to make these all
sum to the identity because the
corresponding projectors will be all
orthogonal so we'll just collect all of
these projectors and then add one final
projector that's just the identity minus
everything everything that we've added
um and so what are the outcomes of this
going to be well remember that the
measurement rule is that our probability
of seeing an outcome is uh the square of
the length of the vector once you
project it onto that projector so in
particular for any pair if XY is
actually contained in s um then the
overlap with the with the vector X Plus
y or the projection onto X Plus Y is is
going to be size 2/ s when you square it
and there'll be zero overlap with x
minus
y on the other hand if exactly one
element of the pair is in s then you'll
have an equal chance of getting either X
Plus y or x minus
y and if X and Y are neither of them are
in s then there's no chance of returning
either because there's zero overlap with
either of the corresponding
vectors and so this will let you solve
both our cardinality estimation problem
and our sampling
problem uh so for the cardinality we can
just use the fact that this rule means
that the difference between how between
your probability of seeing an X Plus Y
and an x minus y is proportional to the
number of pairs that are entirely
contained in s um because you only get
because uh you know the the two the two
cases where they're not contained in s
give zero contribution to that
expectation and then for the sum problem
we can actually just do this measurement
and return you know whatever we see uh X
Plus y or xus Y but with a sign of minus
one if you see x minus y um and so that
means that you kind you you know obey
the promise that we gave that like you
know some sometimes you're allowed to
return a pair with size one overlap but
if you do so it will come with like a
randomly a random
sign so that's how you make um that's
how you can make this sketch I guess I
can stop and ask if there are any
questions about
that
I so you have this set it's fixed and
then later I show up with these pures
and I want to query basically like how
many of them are completely in the set
if I'm like measuring do I destroy my
sketch so I can only like do it oh okay
so okay if you're wondering like how can
you use this stream or I guess what I
was wondering was like if I have many I
I I guess I was imagining the scenario
was like I sketch this big set once and
I have many different queries but it's
it's kind of like a one-time use thing
yeah it's a what it is it is a one-time
usage um later we'll like see how you
can do like uh partial queries where you
um only query with like one pair at a
time and you only destroy the sketch a
little bit um but yeah it is um it is it
is a it is a fully destructive operation
like after you do it what will happen is
your sketch will have been collapsed
down to that pair that you output okay
um I guess I would say that like even in
the classical case where you were doing
sampling it's still effectively it's
still a destructive operation if you
care about your answers being correlated
right because yeah yeah I guess that's
right yeah although like less
destructive yeah yeah depending on your
application the classical one you could
uh use it repeatedly and yeah here it's
um one time only okay cool
any other
questions there's a microphone coming
your
way I'm B curious about the idea behind
this X Plus y x minus y measurement is
it like a inclusion exclusion thing say
if I have more than a pair if I have
like a set of sites n do I have to Cur
like two to the end times like that um
if you had um it's actually worse if you
had sets of
larger than size so if you had sets of
larger than size two you couldn't do
this exclusively with a measurement
because these measurements are
effectively just um
measuring um uh like second order
properties of the of of the vector
because like what you're getting is
based on the overlap you know the the
the the the dot products between the
vector the sketch vector and the
measurement vector um so what
so if you want to query larger sets
basically the best thing you can do is
um do like the classical thing of
sampling multiple times and hoping to
hit everything in you know the larger
set but like taking advantage of the
fact that you're like able to sample
pairs for the cost of sampling one thing
and indeed this is um there's a problem
called the Boolean hidden hyper matching
problem um which corresponds to um
sampling pairs of like size K and just
like you know like so classic so so with
the like sampling size two problems it's
like a complexity of of root n
classically and log n quantumly in
general um up to some stuff about um
floors and ceilings that are still open
it's like n to the one minus uh one
overk complexity to sample size K
pairs
um um classically and N to the one minus
2 overk to size sample size pair
in the quantum
setting thanks that's very
informative is there anything
else okay uh so um that so that was how
you construct the um the sets the the
sketch sorry uh for the kind of the
applications I'm going to mostly like
think about this as like a blackbox um
uh you know a blackbox sketch and we
won't have to use uh the uh underlying
Quantum internals too much although I
will come back later to like how you can
make this sketch into something that's
more useful for the stream but um first
I want to tell you about how you can
about how you can use this to get
Advantage for um a um a couple of
streaming graph algorithms
problems um and
um so you know just uh make sure we're
on the same page here the these are like
problems where you have some very big
graph and you're receiving it uh one
Edge at a time um and then the objective
is to like answer some question about
the graph while using as little space as
possible and um so when you think about
um streaming out about Quantum streaming
algorithms the uh natural question to
ask is are there any problems which use
uh provably less Quantum space than they
would than you'd need classical space if
you wanted to uh solve them in the
classical setting and you know the very
first work that considered this model
actually showed that the answer is yes
you can construct uh Quantum streaming
problems that require exponentially less
space than you would need
classically but um this was for what you
might think of as like a quote unquote
unnatural Problem by which I mean it's
just a problem constructed to show a
complexity
separation so you know the natural F on
question is like are there qu are there
problems that uh people care about like
classically where you get this kind of
uh Quantum space
advantage and so later there was this
work um by Ashley montinaro showing you
can get Quantum Advantage for a very
natural problem which is like this LP
estimation problem when you see a dream
of updates to a
vector but um these advantages only
arise when you have very many passes
over the stream and in particular like
it's like if you have K passes you get a
square root K uh Quantum
Advantage um and so what we're going to
be able to do with this sketch is that
we're going to be able to get Quantum
Advantage for single pass streaming
problems of kind independent classical
interest and and the first of them that
I'm going to tell you about is the
problem of counting triangles in the
Stream so you know triangles here just
being another name for three clicks um
and so this uh this problem is uh very
well studied in classical streaming uh
it has actually some applications in
social sciences and spam detection and
so on but um I think more even more than
that it's uh been studied a lot in both
the theoretical setting and some kind of
more like experimental streaming
algorithm settings because it's a very
natural Benchmark problem it's the
simplest kind of subgraph counting
problem you can think of that is um
non-trivial in that it requires um
information you can't just write you
can't just write down the triangle count
in a graph as a sum of like statistics
of uh like local neighborhoods of graphs
um and
um so um yeah and so this problem um and
I should say this problem uh to do
anything non-trivial in it you need some
parameterization of it um so uh for
instance if you want to if you just
didn't have any lower bound on the
number of triangles in a graph uh then
you wouldn't be able to do anything um
and there's a lot you can say about how
to parameterize it but for our purposes
we're just going to keep it simple and
we're going to imagine aega of M Edge
disjoint triangles in a Theta M sized
graph and so in this setting the kind of
the hardest situation you can have is
that all of your
triangles share a single
vertex um and
specifically um the um what makes this
kind the these kind of graphs hard is
when you receive them as a very large
star followed by a collection of edges
that may or may not uh complete the
neighbors of this star into
triangles now how hard is this well you
can think about what you would do in
kind of like a sampling scenario like
imagine you kept like K of the edges
from this star that you see and then you
decided to check how many of them are
completed into triangles by these uh
matching edges that arise later well if
you kept K edges from your star you
would have a k over M or squared chance
of getting any given triangle and so
since we're assuming that there are like
Theta M triangles that means that you'd
need uh K uh to be equal to about root M
uh this is again the same kind of uh you
know birthday Paradox uh situation we
talked about
before and again the um hardness of the
you can prove that this is classically
hard up to a log fact or this is
classically optimal up to a log Factor
by reducing to Boolean hidden
matching um and as that connection would
suggest you can solve this in uh logm
space with uh with our sketch all you
have to
do is um have um is you know sorry you
can solve it in the two-player setting I
should say so like for Simplicity we we
start by like assuming that like one
person has the the star they sketch it
they send it to the second person who
then uses the matching edges to try and
detect
triangles and so the way you would do
this is you would have um the first
player sketch you know each of the
neighbors of the star make that their
set send the log space Quantum sketch to
the second player and the second player
would just query it with the set of
pairs that just corresponds directly to
those matching
edges and since one of the things that
the sketch is letting you do is ask how
many of these pairs are Con in s the
sketch tells you how many triangles
there are in the
graph and so what that tells you is that
there is an exponential Quantum
Advantage for the uh two-player version
of this like specific uh star in
matching instance of triangle
counting obviously what we wanted was a
streaming algorithm for triangle
counting in general graphs and so we're
going to need to to get rid of both that
like two-player caveat and that specific
instance
caveat
um and I want to talk about the second
part of that
first uh so when you think about like
going to General graphs you can um think
separately about what you have to do to
generalize like the first player's graph
and the second player's graph um
generalizing the first player's graph
actually turns out to be very easy all
you have to do is so before we were
making our set s be you know the all of
these neighbors of the star
vertex now we're going to make our set s
just contain every Edge in the original
graph and so then when we go to query um
whether the edges in the second graph
form triangles with the first graph
we'll make our pairs be uh UV UW for
every Edge in the second matching and
every vertex you know in the whole
vertex set and this is still going to be
a disjoint set of pairs because of the
fact that we promis that VW that these
edges VW are all vertex disjoint they
will form a
matching unfortunately it's not quite as
simple to deal with the case where um
the edges in the second part of the
graph the second half of the stream so
to speak don't form a match
in
uh because remember that we needed the
fact that our set of pairs was
disjoint uh and so if for instance the a
second graph like is like say you know a
staron one
vertex uh then we don't have a valid set
of pairs we could get around this by
like copying the sketch you know a
number of times equal to the maximum
degree of the second graph and then you
know quering with and then like
splitting the queries into one for each
Edge in the in the the the the highest
degree vertices of this
graph uh but that's in general
infeasible because that number that
highest degree could be as large as n
and remember that our classical um upper
bound was only
rooten but fortunately it turns out that
the worst case instances the ones that
look like this are actually also ones
that are very easy for classical
algorithms and so I'm not going to go
into much more detail about that but
basically what you can do is you can
take this like Quantum estimator and use
it to solve these instances that are
hard for classical algorithms use a
classical estimator that solves these
instances that are hard for Quantum
algorithms and interpolate between the
two um and this is unfortunately kind of
lossy so rather than like an exponential
Advantage you end up with like an N to
the two- fths versus square root Quantum
space Advantage so it's a um kind of a
provable um Advantage but it is a fairly
small polinomial um so far of course
this is only still for the two-player
setting and we would like something that
works in the
Stream for that we're going to need to
uh uh to expand the capabilities of our
sketch a little bit um and what we're
going to do is we're going to add two
extra things to
it so first we're going to add this uh
swap
operator um
so this is going to be if we we name a
pair
XY and if that pair is either entirely
contained in the set or not in the set
at all uh the operation does
nothing but if exactly one of X and Y um
is in the set then it removes the one
that's there and adds the one that's not
there and our second one is going to be
a partial query
operation so um previously we had this
idea of querying s with a large set of
pairs and um you know both estimating
the overlap but also getting uh but also
sampling those uh pairs contained within
s equally uh what our partial query is
going to do is given a single pair it's
going to let us uh sample it with the
same probability that we would have if
we um present it as a large collection
of
pairs um but if H so that's you know
that's that's that's about proportional
to one / s but we don't want to destroy
our set if our if our query fails
instead when our query fails all that's
going to happen is that we're going to
remove the elements both of the elements
from the pair S if they're
present and as in the full query setting
we're going to have the same caveat that
maybe you can return return P if it has
only size one overlap with s and it will
have a plus minus one sign if you
do and I should say if you do return P
it will actually destroy the sets
um so then what this is going to mean is
that executing a full query like on a
big collection of pairs um is going to
be equivalent to doing one of these you
know these partial queries one at a time
um and it won't actually matter and as
long as the partial queries are
destroyed it don't actually matter what
AUD you do the men um so I'm going to
pause here since this is uh this is
fairly important for understanding the
rest of the talk and just check if there
are any questions about what's going on
here
okay so um we have these two uh extra
operations and these are going to let us
construct and use this sketch in a uh
streaming fashion
so for constructing the set the sketch
now what we can do is we'll start by
initialize before we even process any
part of the stream we're going to
initialize the sketch on a number of
dummy variables which is uh given by the
number you know an upper bound that we
have on the number of edges that we'll
see in the Stream and then um you know
we can maintain a counter that tells us
um after seeing each when you see a new
Edge swap out this dummy variable for
the new Edge that you
saw by using partial queries we can then
query this sketch for triangles one Edge
at a time so for every time you see an
edge you're going to query the sketch
and ask it uh you know do you does this
Edge complete any triangles with the
input that we've seen so far um and um
this is important for making this work
in the Stream because you couldn't store
all of the edges that you want to query
the sketch with uh without like blowing
up your space
complexity and that gives you then uh
like this provable Quantum space
Advantage for this triangle counting
problem um you know you need um oil to m
to the 25s cubits um and uh classically
you would need root M Cub root M
classical bits uh you can also describe
this algorithm for more general settings
of the parameters of the triangle
problem but the expression becomes both
horrendous and not very Illuminating so
I'm going to admit it here uh so that's
what I had to say about triangle
counting um are there any questions
about
that I believe when you were setting up
the problem you assume that all the
triangles are Edge disjoint graph is
that inherent or yes uh so when you have
a lot of triangles that are that overlap
on an edge um that um creates um so the
situation where for instance where every
triangle shares the same Edge um would
require like would rule out any
non-trivial space Advantage um at least
until the number of triangles becomes
super linear in the size of the graph
and that's by a low a reduction to the
indexing problem in communication
complexity which is equally hard for
classical and Quantum communication okay
cool thank
you do you need to know the length of
the
stream um so cini was asking if we need
to know the length of the stream
beforehand and um the answer is yes and
you don't need to know it exactly you
need to know it up to a constant factor
and if you have an overestimate for it
then that would but I guess but yeah if
you have an overestimate for it that's
going to blow up your your space
complexity by a proportional
amount
um because um uh your sampling
probability because what you'd have to
do is you have to set your sketch to be
proportional to the length of the stream
and then your sampling probabilities are
decreasing in the size of the sketch
which means in turn that your
probability of sampling a triangle goes
down by the same
factor okay if there are no other
questions I want to move on to uh saying
uh how you would actually Implement
these two extra like streaming
properties that we said um and remember
that the two things that we want to
implement are Swap and um partial
measurement and so for this like
swapping operation we will actually need
to introduce an additional Quantum
primitive which is this idea of unitary
Evolution um so if you want if you have
one superposition and you want to change
it into a different different
superposition you can do this by
applying uh linear operators to the
corresponding Vector but because um you
know valid um states have to have length
one these need to be length preserving
linear
Transformations but it turns out you
know one very easy length preserving uh
linear transformation is just you swap
uh a pair of basis
elements
um and so if you do this so if you if if
you so if you want to uh implement this
swap XY operation all you do is you take
is you apply the transformation that
swaps the basis elements corresponding
to X and Y uh to the vector uh so as if
you remember the sketch Vector was this
um Vector that's that's supported
exclusively on the elements of s this
means that if X and Y are both in s
you'll do nothing if neither X nor Y is
an S you'll do nothing and if exactly
one of them is an S you will remove
um that one from s and add the other one
to S which is exactly what we promised
for our swap
operation
okay so then um for the partial query
operation we're actually not going to
need to introduce anything new we're
just going to use the same projective
measurement uh primitive that we had
before
um but we but now we're going to care
about what actually happens with this
like collapsing oper this collapsing
effect um so when we go to do a
measurement a partial query with a
single uh pair XY we're just going to
measure with three projectors one onto
X+ y one onto x minus y and one onto the
rest of the universe or the rest of the
vector space corresponding to the
universe I should say so this means that
your probability of returning either X
Plus y or xus Y is going to be exactly
the same as it was when you were
measuring with a big uh collection of
projectors but if you don't return
either X Plus y or x minus y what you're
going to do is you're going to project
um this state onto uh the
space um Less on this onto the space uh
less the projectors onto X Plus y and x
minus y in other words the space with
the span of X and Y
removed um and that exactly corresponds
to is deleting X and Y from the same M
so again your partial queries are doing
exactly um you know your partial query
operation is doing exactly what we uh
what we
wanted and that's the uh last Quantum
thing that I'm going or the last kind of
quantum uh primitive that I'm going to
mention in this talk so um yes yeah I'll
stop and ask if there any questions
about that before I move on to our like
last uh streaming
application
okay so uh when we uh talked about
triangle counting we got like this
provable space Advantage but you know it
had a couple of caveats right a it was
only polinomial and not even that large
A polinomial and B um it was for like a
pretty specific part of the parameter
range so here I'm going to talk about
another problem where you can get
exponential
Advantage um and that
doesn't Depend and you know that doesn't
depend on parameterizing the input and
this actually is going to be for the
same maximum directed cut problem that
you heard about earlier this week um but
you know just to refresh your memory
this problem is we have a directed uh
graph which we receive one directed Edge
at a time and um we want to know what is
the maximum directed cut size so the a
directed cut being you know you assign
every vertex in the graph either Zer or
one and then an edge is cut by the
directed cut if it goes from zero to one
um so in this case the directed cut
value is five feel free to check that if
you want um and um I should emphasize
here that our objective is just to
Output an approximation to the size of
the directed cut you don't have to
return the actual like description of
the cut and in particular we care about
uh getting an alpha oximation you know
defined as returning some value that's
between the real value and Alpha times
the real
value so just to recap um uh you know
what U is already known about this so
you know hey there's these results
showing that if you want to get better
than a 49ths approximation you need at
least routen space
classically um and this like actually
older work by fed and Joseph shows that
you can actually get better than a 49th
approximation if you have um you know
this like uh snapshot of the graph or
what we can also think call like a you
know a first-degree bias histogram so
it's this is like a count of how of you
know how many edges go from vertices of
kind of one uh range of biases to
another I'll be a bit more specific
about that in the next slide and of
course as you saw earlier this week uh
this um you know this rout this like
routen lower bound is actually so tight
you can get a routen space uh streaming
algorithm that achieves
it and what I want to tell you about is
um a result saying that you can actually
uh estimate this histogram and therefore
um get a better than 49ths approximation
to the max cut value in polylog n space
by using the same sketching
primitive um and so to describe how you
do that first I want to get a bit bit
more specific about this kind of like
idea of like a histogram of
biases um so whole the definition of a
the bias of a Vertex is it's the
difference between its in degree and
it's it's outdegree and its in degree
normalized by the degree
itself and so then the problem that
we're trying to solve with this
streaming algorithm is that we're given
a partitioning of the biases into uh you
know from so the biases range from minus
one to plus one we're given a
partitioning of them into these
contiguous chunks and we want to know
you know for each uh pair of these um
chunks like how many B how many edges
there are that start in uh one bias
class and go to another bias
class and so to explain how you can uh
do this with a Quantum algorithm I want
to return to this like two-player
setting um that we started with you know
the the Alice and Bob setting and think
about just having like Alice and Bob
both having
graphs um and Alice trying to send Bob a
short description of her graph that will
let him um estimate uh how many uh you
know estimate this that the the bias
histogram of their joint
inputs
so estimating like how Alice's edges
contribute to this histogram is actually
very easy because what as can do is she
could just randomly sample her edges and
then like to each of those samples she
would attach the biases and the degrees
of the two end points send them over to
Bob and uh he could then look at his own
input and say okay well what are the
bias since I know the bias in the degree
analysis graph like I'll find out what
the bias is in the graph as a whole
using my graph and then uh you know slot
them into the right place in this this
histogram so the the challenge then is
uh find is figuring out how to sample
these like head tail degree pairs degree
well sorry I should say degree and
outdegree pairs so bias and degree pairs
uh from Alice's graph corresponding to
uh you know individual edges in Bob's
graph so that we can figure out how
Bob's uh edges correspond to this
histogram and what we can do is and here
we're going to start by thinking about
again this easy case where Bob just has
a matching uh is we could use our sketch
to sample like labeled pairs of Alice's
vertices corresponding to Bob's edges so
Alice would like sketch her vertices
along with their like biases and degrees
and she would uh then send those along
to um uh to to Bob and Bob would like
sample from it using this like set of
pairs I should say that like actually
implementing this requires like a bit of
extra work so you have to like course
analysis possible biases because our
sketch doesn't actually let you say oh I
want to sample a Vertex V and then tell
me it's label you actually have to name
its label when you sample it but um as
long as you only need like a limited
resolution of Alice's biases this is not
that big a
problem the bigger problem is that well
in general Bob doesn't have a matching
so uh what can we do if Bob does not
have a
matching well now this time we actually
have um what we can do
or this time you know we we we we can
actually do something a bit nicer than
what we could do in the Triangle
counting case and we'll start by like
imagining that Alice um knew how many
edges Bob had instant to each of her
vertices if she did what she could do is
she could copy each of her vertices with
multiplicity equal to Bob's uh you know
that that vert vertex's degree in Bob's
graph and sketch you know all of those
copies Bob could then when he went to
measure he could like copy each of his
matching uh uh his each of his pairs in
the same multiplicity so he'd still be
uh you know obeying the disjointness
role and this wouldn't actually cause
any problems for our complexity remember
that like sketching more things is in
general um not optimal because it
decreases your probability of sampling
since that's like one over the size of
the set but uh because the sum over
Alice's vertices of Bob's degrees is at
most this number of size the number of
edges in the graph she'd still be
sampling with probability like one over
total number of edges in the graph uh
and so and and so she'd still be able to
get like an accurate estimate of this
histogram the problem of course with
this approach is that as doesn't
actually know what Bob's uh what ver
degrees her her verses are going to have
in Bob's
input but what she can do is use her own
degrees as a as a proxy for Bob's
degrees now there aren't actually any
guarantees on how her degrees are going
to correspond to Bob's degrees so how is
this useful well it's useful because in
the case where the degree of a Vertex in
her input is much smaller than the
degree of a vertex in Bob's input then
her input doesn't actually matter at all
because the bi the bias of a Vertex um
is going to be you know the vi the bias
of Any Given vertex in the unified graph
will only uh will be determined by Bob's
input in the case where it's like degree
in Bob's input is much
higher so what that means then is you
can combine like a classical sampling
approach um where um uh with the that
like handles all of the cases that this
this this this this Quantum protocol
isn't useful for with this Quantum
sampling protocol to solve this like
two-player bias histogram estimation
problem in only polylog of npace um and
the reason this is polylog of npace
rather than log npace is because we kind
of have to do something different for
each uh possible for each like um degree
of for each degree Alice's vertices can
have so we split it into like this
exponentially increasing set of degree
classes um but I'm going to um brush
over the details of that uh and instead
what I want to move on to for the like
final part of describing this this
algorithm is how you can actually do all
of this in a uh streaming
setting so ideally based on this
description what we'd like to do in the
streaming set
is maintain a sketch of uh the vertices
in the graph that come attached where
like each vertex has you know this C and
description of its bias and where each
vertex bias pair is U maintained in
multiplicity corresponding to the degree
of that
vertex then as we see edges coming in we
would like to uh you know measure uh for
each Edge UV we'd like to do a partial
query of uh U bias of u v bias of V or
for each possible you know cost and
value of the bias of U and the bias of v
and use and then once we get one of
these samples we can then like you know
look at uh which edges are incident to
that vertex in the rest of the stream
and get a final estimate of its bias
which will plug into our estimate of the
bias
histogram and then you know we'll we can
just do some some classical sampling
stuff to you know deal with all of the
cases where these biases are um
dominated by edges that arrive after UV
so this corresponds to the case in the
two-player setting where um Bob uh where
um Bob's degree for a Vertex was much
higher and therefore Bob's input
determined the degree of that
vertex the problem with this approach is
that we can't actually do this first
part if we wanted to maintain this set
of um you know vertices this set where
like each vertex appeared in
multiplicity corresponding to its degree
we would need to actually know this
degree when we see an eduv and um by
know this degree I mean even like you
you would only need to know the degree
in edges that arrive before UV but even
that is something you can't actually
like legally maintain because uh you're
not allowed to use like Omega of the
Omega of end space it would require
so
instead um instead I want to kind of
describe at a very high level how you
can get around this problem and for the
remainder of this slide just kind of
assume that instead of trying to
maintain biases I'm just trying to
maintain the degrees of
vertices
um so the idea is that you want to
maintain you want to maintain each
vertex in multiplicity equal to its
degree so what you're going to do is
you're going to copy each vertex going
to add a copy of a ver of each vertex to
the set s every time you see an edge
incident to it and you're going to use
the number of times that you've done
this to encode its
degree so the way that you'll do this is
that when you add a Vertex to S you'll
always add it with this label that says
zero and you'll also increment every
like copy already in s the label of
every copy in every already in s by what
which you can do with these swap
operations and so that means that now
for each vertex s will contain v i for
every I from zero to like the degree of
the vertex in the input you've seen so
far and so then you can query um whether
this vertex exists in the set with
degree at least some threshold by doing
queries um that like specify this uh
threshold degree label in
them now doing the actual algorithm uh
becomes actually quite a bit more
complicated because you you what you
care about is the biases not just the
degrees so you need to do this separate
thing to encode the uh the say like the
out degrees of the
vertex and
um uh you know it's unfortunately not
possible to do this by just repeating
that but um I'm going to kind of skim
over the details about how you do that
since they're not that enlightening and
just give you the final result which is
that there is a polylog n space Quantum
streaming algorithm that successfully
approximates this like bias histogram
and that therefore gives you a better
than 49ths approximation to the maximum
diecut value of the
graph um and I want to know that this is
in contrast to what you get with the
undirected version of Max cut where you
can actually prove that there is no
Quantum advantage possible for any
approximation ratio that you would care
about so that brings me to the end of
what I wanted to talk about um so just
to wrap up here we have a uh simple like
log space Quantum sketch that allows you
to solve um the problem of sampling uh
pairs from a set with the same
complexity that classically you'd need
to sample
Singletons it gets you some Quantum
space advantages for this for for the
problem of counting triangles in the
Stream it gets you exponential
advantages for the streaming version of
directed
cut and now just a couple of open
questions one uh you know what is the
correct complexity for um triangle
counting because our lower bounds that
we know still leave open the possibility
that you could get an exponential
Quantum Advantage for this problem
and second of all um is there a way of
like characterizing which constraint
satisfaction problems admit Quantum
space Advantage because we've seen that
directed cut does and mac and you know
regular Max cut
doesn't maybe there's like some property
that you can describe that tells you
when these advantages are possible and
and uh that's all I wanted to say so
thank you for
[Applause]
listening
questions
joh um I have a question regarding the
approximation ratio you just briefly
mentioned so um um is that gonna uh for
different approximation ratio uh is that
going to change the like Quantum
Advantage uh say from exponential
Quantum advantage to just polinomial
Advantage um so So Below 49ths uh
there's a classical algorithm that
achieves polylog that achieves that in
polylog end space above one half um the
um same results that tell you that you
can't um get Quantum Advantage for Max
cut would also tell you that you can't
get Quantum Advantage for um uh for for
this problem and between um this 0 435
and and one half the question is still
open just as it is in the classical
setting okay gotcha
thanks can you use these type of
techniques to get like Dynamic like
insertion deletion
algorithms so um the so so so so the
sketch is inherently
um a bit hostile to deletions uh okay
so when you think of inserting things
into the sketch there you could get
insertion and
deletion with the caveat that you would
pay that your like price would be the
total number of updates rather than the
total number of edges because basically
what you could do is you could say okay
I'm going to do a swap operation that
takes this thing I want to delete and
turns it into junk um if actually I
guess if you know that you're only going
to delete stuff that is definitely there
then you could transform it back into a
dummy Edge and maybe not pay that
overhead but the bigger problem is the
measurement operators are irreversible
so I'm not aware of any like General
approach that you could use to make um
either of these algorithms work in a
dynamic setting because they depend on
doing the measurements one at a
time other
questions um I think it's related to the
last question and also uh it may be a
silly question uh um is there a Quantum
Advantage I don't allow my sketch to be
destructive like is there impossibility
serum saying you
can't you're asking
um I I guess I'm I'm not sure how to to
to think
about I I guess I'm not sure how to
understand what what what what what the
answer to that should correspond to like
so this sketch very much just depends on
doing measurements which are inherently
inherently a destructive thing you could
in principle imagine a uh streaming
problem where there was a Quantum
advantage that came from an algorithm
that did all of its measurements at like
you know in postprocessing and that some
and that
therefore
um uh you know and that therefore
allowed like um insertions and deletions
and therefore was like not destructive
while processing the stream but I'm not
aware of any problem that you know
evinces such an
advantage certainly these ones
definitely depend on the destructive
nature
of I think a natural setting would be if
I have multiple cues like doing the
stream then uh is it just impossible
to um
hand well any if you have a query that
like if you have a query that's not
destructive then it's in some sense an
inherently classical query so um I mean
I I I maybe I'm not understanding the
setting you're thinking of correctly but
I don't
uh I don't think there so when I say
destructive I mean like and it
permanently modifies the sketch like
it's not
um like as we saw in like the partial
query sense it's not necessarily like
making the sketch totally useless but um
but yeah like the the the the fact that
Quantum measurements change the state
you measure is um you know inherent the
to how they
work hi um so if I if I understand
correctly like for the max cut lower
bounds it's like if we want to beat half
approximation for both classical and
Quantum it requires um Omega and space
right that's right yeah um I guess
if if we're in the setting where like we
allow for Omega n space and like maybe
want to do like
an like some sort of like Epsilon
approximation um I guess is it possible
there's
like um like a Quantum like space
Advantage if we like consider dependence
on Epsilon like is that something we
even care about um so in terms of the
dependence on Epsilon
um I guess I don't know of any lower
bounds that would rule that out because
yeah like if you if you have omega of
end
space um I think like classically you
can get like um like like n over Epsilon
squar is I think is I think enough to
get you there just by doing like
uniformly subsampling the edges
um I'm
not I
would guess that that's probably optimal
for the classical setting but for the
quantum setting as as well but I haven't
thought about it uh um in
[Applause]
detail okay let's thank John once
again